hoy Luis Ignacio Luna da Silva el
presidente de Brasil comienza su séptimo
viaje internacional en menos de seis
meses de gobierno el primer destino será
Italia donde se encontrará con Sergio
matarella el presidente de la nación y
con el alcalde de Roma sin embargo de
momento no está previsto ningún
encuentro bilateral con Georgia meloni
la presidenta del gobierno que
representa a la extrema derecha sí habrá
un encuentro con el Papa Francisco en el
que según Lula se hablara de la Guerra
de Ucrania de la lucha contra la
desigualdad además sabemos que Lula le
quiere invitar para este mes de octubre
a Belén de pará en la amazonía brasileña
donde se celebra el exilio de Nazaret
una famosa procesión que el año pasado
llegó a congregar a más de 2,5 millones
de fieles después de Italia Lula irá a
Francia donde se reunirá con el
presidente Emmanuel macron en este caso
ha dicho que que va a presionar para que
finalmente apruebe el acuerdo entre el
mercosur y la Unión Europea recordamos
que la semana pasada la presidenta de la
comisión europea urso la founderlayen
visitó Brasil le prometió Se comprometió
en realidad a que este acuerdo esté
aprobado para finales del año Lula
volvió a criticar el mecanismo de
sanciones para los estados que no
cumplen con todas las cláusulas de este
acuerdo y reiteró de nuevo que un
acuerdo internacional como este tiene
que estar basado sobre la confianza
mutua y no sobre la desconfianza y las
sanciones